in a future plagued by dystopia our
brave fighter pilot Adam Reed Ryan
Reynolds takes a daring gamble to save
his beloved wife Laura determined to
alter their Grim fate he embarks on a
risky Mission stealing a powerful time
jet to transport himself back to the
year 2018. however unforeseen
circumstances arise and Adam finds
himself injured and stranded in the
unfamiliar year of 2022 after a
turbulent and chaotic Crash Landing
here's where the story takes an
intriguing twist the focus shifts to a
young boy named Adam who is just 12
years old in the year 2022. tragically
he has just lost his father Louis a year
earlier Adam's life is far from easy as
he endures bullying at school and finds
himself suspended for a fight that was
not even his fault not only that but he
feels distant from his mother Ellie as
well and a sense of loneliness engulfs
him one fateful night when Young Adam is
home alone he stumbles upon a wounded
stranger who turns out to be none other
than his future self at first the
younger Adam is skeptical and hesitant
to trust this stranger who has been
claiming to be him but Fate has a way of
revealing itself as future Adam
unintentionally mentions the names of
both the younger Adam and his loyal
companion Hawking the dog that is the
moment when the pieces start falling
into place and Young Adam realizes The
Unbelievable Truth before him this
injured man is no one else but rather
his future self however the future Adam
is still injured and unable to fly due
to a safety feature in the time jet this
leaves our dynamic duo with no other
choice but to embark on their mission
together to make matters more intense
they soon come under attack from
myosaurian the menacing leader of the
dystopian world and her formidable
assistant Christos but just when it
seems all hope is lost a miraculous turn
of events occurs Laura believed to be
dead emerges as their Savior and manages
to save their life it turns out that she
had not actually died but instead she
faked her death and had been living off
the grid in an undisclosed location the
future Adam although very confused is
ecstatic to find out that his wife is
still alive following their harrowing
escape from the attack the reunited Trio
takes the opportunity to compare their
findings which leads them to a shocking
realization after the brilliant inventor
Lewis read created time travel and
subsequently met his demise myosaurian
seized control of this revolutionary
technology Laura during her visit to the
year 2018 uncovered the disturbing truth
that sorian had been covertly
influencing her past self manipulating
events to ensure her own future wealth
and power to safeguard her dark secret
sorian orchestrated the assassination of
Laura although Laura miraculously
survived the attempt on her life the
destruction of her time jet left her
stranded in the past unable to reunite
with Adam due to the absence of her
means of transportation the reunion is
abruptly interrupted by the arrival of
saurian's goons forcing Laura to hold
them off in a thrilling battle while the
two atoms escaped the year 2018 with
their lives hanging in the balance they
make a daring leap into the past hoping
to change the course of history and
prevent the dystopian nightmare that
awaits them all in the year 2018 both
the older and younger versions of the
atoms realized the importance of seeking
their father Louis Reed it is evident
that his Aid would be crucial in their
mission however their father is
extremely cautious of the potential
repercussions on the fragile fabric of
time and hesitates to involve himself at
all despite their Earnest appeals Lewis
remains Resolute in his decision
unwilling to offer any assistance to his
desperate children however things take a
thrilling turn when myosaurian the
cunning leader from 2050 encounters her
past self and warns her about the
existence of Adam this unexpected
encounter disrupts the delicate balance
of time creating ripples in the fabric
of reality the plot thickens as the two
versions of saurian come face to face
the stakes are raised and the stage is
set for an epic battle that will shape
the destiny of our protagonists
meanwhile the two atoms find solace in a
motel where they bond over their shared
feelings and frustrations regarding
their father's reluctance to help the
night is filled with emotions as they
reflect on their complicated
relationship and the challenges that
they have yet to face the following day
armed with determination the Adams set
out on a mission to destroy the time
travel machine itself as they arrive at
sorian Technologies they're suddenly
ambushed by saurian soldiers but just
when it seems all hope is lost an
unexpected twist occurs Lewis Reed
appears and comes to their rescue he has
had a change of heart and now agrees to
guide them in their Quest Louis reveals
a vital piece of information destroying
the machine alone won't eradicate time
travel as long as sorian possesses the
algorithm with all the necessary
calculations and constraints to control
the process the stakes are higher than
ever as they Race Against Time to stop
saurian's nefarious plans in a parallel
timeline the older version of saurian
captures the younger atom adding another
layer of tension and danger to the
unfolding events but 2050 Adam buys time
and manages to create an opportunity for
2022 Adam to escape from saurian's
clutches with a daring move he pushes
her gun away diverting her attention and
allowing his younger self to break free
however chaos ensues as inerrant bullet
damages the seal restraining the
electromagnetic field causing it to grow
uncontrollably the Reeds desperately try
to find a solution but their efforts
seem futile the older sorian realizing
she's losing her grip on the situation
resorts to threatening Louie's life to
force him into surrendering the
algorithm in a tense moment the the
younger Adam warns that saurian's
bullets are armor-piercing but Lewis
remains Resolute with no other choice in
sight sorian pulls the trigger but fate
intervenes the path of the bullet is
altered by the surging electromagnetic
field and instead of hitting Lewis it
strikes the 2018 version of saurian
instantly eliminating both of them from
existence after narrowly escaping the
cataclysmic implosion of saurian
Technologies the Reeds make it back to
the safety of their home emotions run
high as they take a moment to reconcile
and heal the wounds that have plagued
their family in a beautiful display of
connection and unity they decide to play
a game of catch symbolizing their
Newfound Harmony following the
successful fulfillment of their mission
the atoms find themselves at the
crossroads of returning to their
respective timelines in an unexpected
twist the younger atom is transported to
a new reality in 2022 where he never
endured the painful experience of being
suspended from school in this
transformed timeline he has undergone a
profound personal growth relinquishing
his deep-seated anger and resentment and
embracing a more positive and hopeful
outlook on life in a truly heart warming
moment he extends a gesture of love and
understanding towards his mother Ellie
using an ethereal Echo as a symbol of
his profound affection and Newfound
empathy the scene then shifts to a
future time where Adam has matured and
found contentment in his life he crosses
paths with Laura during a flight
training lecture to his Amusement Laura
realizes that she has mistakenly entered
the wrong building on the bustling
campus with his natural gentlemanly
demeanor Adam graciously offers to
accompany her and walks by her side as
they make their way to the correct
destination as they stroll together Adam
playfully remarks that he has got plenty
of time his remark of having plenty of
time brings a smile to Laura's face
creating an immediate connection between
them their conversation flows
effortlessly and they seem to be
genuinely curious about each other's
lives their bond is undeniable and can
be felt strongly it is pretty clear that
a brighter future awaits them both and
this is when the credits start rolling
so what are your thoughts about the
movie did it have a satisfactory ending
let us know in the comments down below
click on one of the two videos on screen
right now